يعد عمر بال الطعام لضيوف الخاصين انه اول
موريتاني يصل الى سنسناتي في ولايه اوهايو
اما الضيوف فموريتانيا
انا اول مهاجر من قريتي اتي الى هنا الان
لا يوجد كثير من الموريتانيين هم قله هنا
عائشه ص من بين الواصلين الجدد الى
سنسناتي سلكت للبحث عن حياه جديده في
امريكا سبلا بعيده عن الطرق المعهوده فقد
علمت من خلال منصه واتساب في مايو ايار
الماضي عن طريق جديد من موريتانيا الى
الولايات المتحده عبر نيكارجوا في امريكا
الجنوبيه حسابات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
روجت للطريق ووصفت الرحله بعبارات ملهمه
ومبهجه لكن الحقيقه ان الهجره الى امريكا
هي الاكثر خطوره بسبب الطريق الذي تمر به
وطبيعه المهربين الذين يتم التعامل معهم
عائشه قالت انها تعرضت للتضليل بشان مخاطر
الرحله والحياه في
امريكا الطريق الذي سلكته للوصول الى هنا
ليس جيدا لقد سرق هاتفي
واموالي الطريق الذي جلب عائشه صال نقل
الاف الموريتانيين الاخرين الى الولايات
المتحده اخيرا حركه هجره مفاجئه وغير
متوقعه الضوء على القوه المتزايده لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لتغيير تدفق الهجره
ومساراتها في جميع انحاء
العالم